carrusel de las artes maría carolina
piña
sí
[Música]
un placer saludarles desde nuestros
estudios en parís para este nuevo número
de nuestro programa donde exploramos la
rica actualidad cultural francesa y
estos son los temas que les hemos
preparado para hoy
carrusel de las artes los lleva a la
prestigiosa escuela govern de parís una
de las más reconocidas a nivel mundial
en materia de animación allí conversamos
con el mexicano rama james ganador del
emmy awards a la mejor película
estudiantil por su corto la bestia
los cines están abiertos en francia y en
las pantallas oscuras se proyectan entre
otros la comedia francesa adiós licón y
ve a la batalla un drama que tiene lugar
durante la segunda intervención francesa
en méxico en 1861 y en nuestra crónica
musical conversaremos con el pianista
alexis bayón excepción y su grupo de
jazz quienes mezclan en su música
sonoridades orientales y los ritmos de
américa latina
[Música]
hola
comenzamos nuestro programa de hoy en
una de las escuelas más prestigiosas del
mundo en lo que se refiere al cine de
animación se llama gove land se
encuentra en parís y por sus aulas han
pasado artistas que hoy trabajan en los
mejores estudios de dibujos animados del
mundo y de hecho ya conocimos a un
ilustre egresado de esa escuela ha
venido de méxico es un reportaje
exclusivo para carrusel de melissa
barracón rf y vídeos por estos pasillos
han pasado los creadores de personajes y
películas de fama mundial
[Música]
el primer estudiante en haber producido
un éxito mundial fue 10 cosa quien creó
los minions también estaría sattouf el
autor de la historieta el árabe del
futuro tuvimos a christoph según quien
luego se volvió director de animación de
dreamworks y ahora trabaja para netflix
del proyecto de la animación de estudio
y muerte de gimeno traver
he aquí los antiguos estilos
del kung fu
manda
he dicho anda
en la película kung fu panda' participó
de un grupo de egresados adaptamos sin
cesar nuestros programas a las
necesidades del mercado global así los
estudiantes ingresan al mundo
profesional al graduarse
las exigencias de entrada son altas en
woodlands sólo el 30 por ciento de los
800 candidatos que cada año postulan a
la carrera de animación logra un cupo en
la escuela ocupando mundos de julión
exigimos a los estudiantes tener muy
buen nivel de dibujo pero más que todo
saber dibujar el movimiento no nos
interesa una naturaleza muerta sino la
manera de representar el movimiento de
una hoja con una o dos pinceladas
también buscamos candidatos que quieran
contar historias y además que les guste
trabajar en equipo
en google a la mitad del departamento de
animación lo componen estudiantes
extranjeros cursan un programa
completamente en inglés
de hecho cuando se graduó nuestra
primera promoción internacional ganamos
nuestro primer año award entonces esa
diversidad es nuestro pequeño milagro
lleve a 770 que distinciones en grandes
academias y festivales películas y
cortos difundidos en pantallas en todo
el planeta los talentos de gol han
entrado en el radar incluso de grandes
firmas de hollywood
[Música]
ramiro thames es la estrella mexicana de
la escuela de animación de gol
su talento fue apoyado por el
multipremiado guillermo del toro el
cineasta junto con la exhibidora
cinépolis lo becaron para que estudiar
en parís
y todo el mundo en la animación conoce
la escuela entonces tenía una idea de
más o menos cómo era pero yo yo nunca
estudié animación excepto aquí
anteriormente entonces para mí e incluso
el la experiencia de una escuela era
totalmente nueva porque nunca había
estudiado en una universidad ni nada por
el estilo
han sido creo yo los mejores dos años de
mi carrera y también los más difíciles
[Música]
ramiro es el autor de la bestia un
cortometraje sobre dos desconocidos que
viajan por esta red de trenes que toman
los migrantes centroamericanos rumbo a
eeuu
se acaban los jueguitos ahora es un
polizón a bordo de la bestia y este tren
es eterno perdona una
cuando yo estaba ya me tocaba muy
seguido pasar por las vías y ver el tren
pasar una de las cosas que a mí me
entusiasmaba en aquellas caminadas era
eso porque no usar la animación un medio
que de cajón especialmente en mi país se
usa para contar cosas bonitas de nuestro
país para contar algo que no es tan
bonito pero que a lo mejor si vale la
pena contar porque el transformar al
tren ando una bestia en si el tema real
del tren es gigantesco y existe
millones y millones de historias que
pasan aquí por millones de razones y con
millones de finales que no están
representados aquí aquí solamente están
representados dos personajes que son
víctimas de este tren pero hay de todo
en el tren a entonces
quisimos un poco resumir todo lo que
pudiera pasar todo lo malo que pasa en
el tren haciendo el tren un monstruos en
una alegoría de su nombre
también me gusta la bestia goblin la del
amor
[Música]
en abril 2021 la bestia recibió un a new
world el equivalente del oscar para el
cine de animación pero pasar por las
aulas de copla le abrió nuevas puertas
actualmente estoy trabajando
estudio la casete que estoy trabajando
en la serie de que andy tartakovsky
prime al escribiendo más contenido que
esperaría hacer los próximos años
el calle
todos mis sueños
[Música]
los cines reanudaron con su público tras
la mejoría de la situación sanitaria en
francia y dentro de la inmensa oferta de
películas rescatamos dos cintas una
comedia galardonada con el premio de la
academia francesa y un drama ambientado
justamente en mexico
[Música]
y vuelve a las salas oscuras luego del
cierre de más de seis meses de los cines
en francia esta cinta de albert dupontel
cuenta la historia de una mujer que
decide buscar a su hijo abandonado
cuando se entera de que está gravemente
enferma
[Música]
y su búsqueda la lleva a conocer a dos
agentes de la administración francesa
que le ayudarán a buscar a ese bebé dado
en adopción veinte años atrás esta
comedia con la codiciada virginie fija
fue declarada la mejor película francesa
en la última ceremonia de los premios
césar y un estreno en francia nos lleva
al méxico de mediados del siglo 19 junto
a louis un fotógrafo que pretende
documentar la guerra colonial pero las
dificultades se multiplican
obstaculizando el trabajo de louis quien
siempre llega tarde para tomar fotos de
los combates de bajo confianza
pero no sé
en medio de su desgracia louis conoce a
un indígena local protagonizado por el
actor costarricense lay nar gómez este
primer largometraje de ojal yang viernes
la emoción se presenta como un road
movie que se desarrolla en la aridez la
exuberancia y la rudeza de esa época
[Música]
ahora ya de nuestra crónica musical con
una tal ya olivares que nos va a hacer
descubrir a un grupo de jazz liderado
por un ex ingeniero y diplomático franco
ruso que lo dejó todo para dedicarse a
la música y el resultado natalia es una
historia de viajes y de amor una
historia de amor y los invito a viajar
desde ahora mismo
[Música]
desde el distrito 1 de parís en el
pasaje oriente pasaje de la verdad les
invitó a viajar por todo el mundo
gracias a compositor pianista del grupo
long alexis
hola alexis por la natalidad
muy bien
[Música]
o acaso no significa color en persa esto
lo supe gracias a un diccionario franco
parisi que mi padre había olvidado
encima de una mesa cuando lo abrí me
gustaron mucho las palabras escritas en
fonética me pareció que long el color
era muy buen concepto para todo lo que
tiene que ver con la música en el
sentido general del término
long es un color inventado por el exilio
excepciones un color el nombre de su
álbum pero también el nombre de su banda
que inicialmente era un cuarteto pero a
medida que fueron encontrando diferentes
músicos se fue transformando y
evolucionando se la cura es el color en
sentido general incluso cuando se habla
de color armónico es justamente esa idea
la que surge en el disco ahora bien para
responder a la pregunta de si se trata
de un trío o un sexteto pues es un
proyecto de geometría variable que va
desde el trío contrabajo batería y piano
hasta el sexteto con percusión flauta y
trompeta pasando por el cuarteto
original que incluía la trompeta
[Música]
hablabas de una historia de amor en
maría carolina y efectivamente alexi
bayonet sesión se enamoró de la música
durante sus viajes cuando era
diplomático e ingeniero se fue
trasladando a países como uzbekistán
venezuela-cuba etcétera y una verdadera
historia de amor que lo hizo cambiar
radicalmente de vida
porque es ante todo una experiencia de
vida porque como ingeniero y diplomático
tuve que viajar mucho uzbekistán rusia
pero también tengo una experiencia
musical pues durante mis viajes
escuchaba música constantemente en
américa latina y sobre todo en oriente
comience a investigar además como el
grupo tenemos un percusionista nils
extra que tocar ritmos afrocubanos pues
hay mucha inspiración que nos viene de
américa latina especialmente de cuba
donde yo estudié piano y también de
venezuela donde estuve en muchas cosas
me vienen de américa latina
[Música]
luego windows
gracias natalio olivares y justamente
vamos a trasladarnos con este grupo long
los despedimos con el tema a mali y
muchísimas gracias por haber estado con
nosotros cuídense mucho y hasta la
próxima
jaua
[Música]
crisis
todesca sin baile
[Música]